В якому стані українці, що прибули з Китаю?
Усі евакуйовані з Китаю зараз у безпеці.
Вони в теплі, нагодовані, у них є зв'язок.
Я дуже сподіваюся, що вони гарно відпочинуть і з ними все буде добре.
Наші медики забезпечили достатній рівень захисту,
і вони у фізичній та епідеміологічній безпеці.
Як вони спілкуються з родичами?
У них є засоби зв'язку.
Завтра ми переконаємося у тому, що
в кожного з них немає проблем сконтактувати з тими,
з ким вони хочуть сконтактувати.
У Китаї залишаються ще кілька сотень українців. Чи є плани якось їм допомагати?
Ми будемо спостерігати за тим, як розвиватиметься ситуація з коронавірусом.
Будемо консультуватися з нашими колегами
зі Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров'я й після цього ухвалювати рішення.
Чи будуть обмеження в сполученні з країнами Азії?
Щойно будуть - ми повідомимо.
Чи справді в Україні немає закладів, де можна
забезпечити всі норми епідеміологічної безпеки?
В Україні дуже багато закладів, де можна
забезпечити сучасні норми. У тому числі той заклад,
про який ми сказали. Це режимний об'єкт.
Там працює персонал, який нам дуже добре зрозумілий.
Я вже казав неодноразово про те, що ми планували
цю операцію з розумінням, що можуть бути якісь провокації.
Дякувати Богу, всі живі-здорові.
Скільки міст відмовили?
Ніхто не відмовляв.
Ніхто?
Дивіться, що значить "міста відмовили"?
В якій кількості міст були провокації, маніпуляції?
Ми розглядали багато різних варіантів.
Медики висували багато критеріїв до подібних закладів:
де вони мають розміщуватися, яким чином має бути
організований побут, яка має бути архітектура
всередині будівлі - це має бути окрема будівля,
периметр має бути захищений.
Виїжджали на ці об'єкти медики, фахівці з безпеки.
За підсумками всіх цих консультацій оперативний штаб
ухвалив три-чотири варіанти, які ми розглядали
до останнього моменту. Чому був обраний саме цей варіант?
Причин дуже багато. За підсумками 14 днів операції -
я переконаний, вона буде успішною - ми поділимося більшими деталями.
Наприклад, санаторій імені Соїча у Харкові.
Він у нас був у списку. Чому він не годиться?
Бо після аналізу стало зрозуміло, що з Печенізького водосховища
йде забір води до Харкова. І система фільтрації там
така, яка не забезпечує потрібну ситуацію.
Цей об'єкт був знятий. І таких критеріїв було декілька.
Зрештою вийшла така ситуація.
Чому така посилена охорона? Це нагадує якусь спецоперацію.
Ви побачили, що зрештою, вона не була зайвою?
У вас була інформація заздалегідь?
Ми бачили, що відбувається.